I was thinking accounting might be a good fit....
...because I really clicked with Oscar and I do have some experience with bookkeeping.
But, we already have a surplus of accountants as it is.
I would work in customer service, HR even.
Those are fully staffed as well.
Are you telling me that there is no one in this entire office...
...that could use an extra pair of hands?
Yes!
I am the CEO and I am telling an employee of mine what to do.
Let me beat around the bush for a second.
Our chairman of the board has some very strong feelings...
Robert, it's all right.
This is very uncomfortable.
Obviously, there's no place for me here, so thank you for trying.
Why don't we just let it go?
No, absolutely not.
Andrew, there must be something you can do, there must be.
Think.
Well, there are a lot of considerations.
I would be eternally grateful.
It's not a bad thing to have the CEO owe you one.
All right.
Well, then welcome aboard!
Yeah, perfect!
So, what happens next?
We get you over to HR and then get you set up with accounting.
Hang on.